now the biden administration continues
to find new and creative ways to
embarrass america on the world stage
even after uh relations with france
deteriorated following a botched
submarine deal back in september vice
president kamala harris apparently
thought that she could i guess smooth
things over with a um fake accent take a
look
with us in government
we campaign with the plan
uppercase t uppercase p d plan
and then the environment is such that
we're expected to defend the plan
even when the first time we roll it out
there may be some glitches and it's time
to reevaluate and then do it again
really it's hard to pick what's worse
china mocking biden openly saying
they're going to take over taiwan putin
built a building up his troop strength
on the ukrainian border getting a waiver
from joe to build his pipeline while joe
is begging opec to produce more oil
almost on a daily basis being rejected
every single time unfortunately it only
gets worse from there as the biden
administration continues to downplay our
most serious geopolitical threats
including and specifically china and
instead continue to talk nonstop about
climate change including blaming our own
military for being a polluter
you can't make this up take a look
speaker pelosi you just presided over a
large increase in the pentagon budget
the pentagon is a larger polluter than
140 countries combined recognizing what
you said we recognize that as well which
is a bigger threat the climate or china
you've heard the secretary talk about
the climate
as a a real and existential national
security threat and it is not just to
the united states but to countries all
over the world
and we consider
china as the number one pacing challenge
for the department both are equally
important
i'm just sure the communist chinese are
building their hypersonic missiles that
can launch nukes uh with the climate in
in mind that's top of mind for them
right now those bizarre remarks come as
threats against america are only
increasing china has zero respect for
joe biden russia knows biden is a
cognitive mess iran is still hell-bent
on getting a nuclear weapon by the
administration seems to be accepting of
that and there is a new terror safe
haven that would be the islamic emirates
of afghanistan and of course biden
continues to leave the border wide open
here with reaction fox news contributor
former secretary of state mike pompeo
so we're talking about
climate change as it relates to our
military weaponry and the communist
chinese are mocking joe biden
threatening to take over taiwan flying
over their airspace with fighter jets
and firing off hypersonic missiles tell
me what's wrong with that mr secretary
boy sean where to begin uh the clip from
vice president harris is just a it's
more than embarrassing on the world
stage the our adversaries watch that and
see weakness they see people who aren't
serious they see people who aren't
determined precisely the opposite of
what we did for four years it feels a
lot more like the carter administration
in terms of how they they view america
as a a danger to the world and apologize
everywhere they go
we need to get serious you just trip
through the russians the chinese
the north koreans the iranians you just
trip through all of our adversaries
these adversaries can see that we're
focused on diversity inclusion in our
military we're focused on trying to fly
our jets with green energy and they're
focused on how to build out a military
that can undo our republic
we need an administration that is
serious about putting america first not
america last as they seem to have done
prioritizing climate change as america's
most significant national security
threat is an enormous mistake
mr secretary i am convinced they see joe
biden as a cognitive mess weak and frail
i am convinced that at some point in the
near future that china will quote
reunify their words with taiwan and i'm
pretty convinced that vladimir putin has
plans to once again make his way into
ukraine your thoughts am i right or am i
likely wrong
well they're certainly increasing the
risk of that it is much more likely
today than it was just
10 months ago well there's going to be
an olympics it looks like in beijing in
just a couple months in february
following that xi xingping will be at
his international pinnacle there's no
reason to think that the stated mission
that he has to put taiwan back under
chinese charity isn't something that
he'll
perceive our administration as being
unserious perceived president biden as
being incompetent he watched afghanistan
he watched us leave americans behind and
have 13 americans killed
i think that the chinese see america
today as a nation in decline without
serious leaders with the capability to
deter i do think that the risk not only
that china will act but the russia will
begin to move whether it's on ukraine or
elsewhere we saw what they did the
colonial pipeline in the united states
of america what what cost have we
imposed on them for that sean i think
the answer is zero we need to be
determined and resolved and re-establish
the deterrence we had for the four years
of our administration
do you believe the biden administration
based on the words of their iranian
envoy are accepting of the idea of a
nuclear-armed iran
yes i i think the iranians believe that
they have a clear pathway to a nuclear
weapon with this administration i think
they are resolved to get both build out
their capacity and to build out a
weapons program and they don't see this
administration as remotely doing the
things necessary to prevent them from
doing this you remember this president
sean criticized us when we took on qasim
sulaimani and took him off the
battlefield saving american lives this
president criticized us when we put real
pain real sanctions on the ayatollah and
his henchmen so they couldn't conduct
terror campaigns around the world
i think the iradians see weakness they
see frailness and they're prepared to
drive a truck through that very
opportunity sean scary times mr
secretary we need the adults back in
charge as always we appreciate you being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else